[Music]
over the last few days people have been
asking me what on earth's happening with
brexit over the last few days people
have been asking me how much longer this
brick sit shower is going to go on and I
can understand that because after all
it's nearly three years since people
voted in the referendum for the UK to
leave the European Union and I
understand that after all it's been
nearly two and a half years of this well
where we're at is that the government
negotiated a deal with the EU and my
preference was for that deal to be
passed by Parliament and we could leave
with the EU on that base the EU on that
basis well where we're at is people
simply no longer give a flying and right
now I can't see that mood changing the
good people of Newport West were asked
to vote at a by-election last week and
the turnout was at an historical low
clearly they'd rather have root canal
treatment without anesthetic than
actually cast a bloody vote truthfully
who can blame them this will mean
compromise on both sides if we
politicians stop about and actually get
something done you lot will have to
start voting again that's why for me
brexit will always mean actually travel
you've just answered him for me I wasn't
say what we were clearly our system is
broken and what we need is new people we
need fresh blood it's funny I met this
young guy recently called Jake Schenker
who's got a book coming out in a few
months that everybody needs to read and
what he talks about is the fact that
we've got to a place for the first time
where our so-called experts the people
that we rely on actually don't have
answers and so what's happening is on
the ground people are coming up with
solutions themselves and so I think
what's going to happen over the next
five to ten years is a whole new wave of
talent coming
through getting involved in our
political process that wouldn't have
otherwise because our politicians
haven't got a clue
let's get you you were brave enough at
the last election to actually put your
put your head about the power this all
focuses on the fact that at the election
last week
clearly the disconnect is massive have a
36 is appalling what do you say and
would you ever do it again well I think
it's very simple I think politics is
broken in this country and people trot
out that sentence but it really really
is there's a huge disconnection between
what people what is going on in
Parliament and what is going on around
people's kitchen tables at homes and in
terms of people's views being
represented properly and not we need to
have significant reforms so I would
start by immediately pushing a campaign
for electoral reform so proportional
representation I think is the first
thing that we need to make sure we've
got a parliament that reflects different
views even if you don't like those views
irrelevant
I think then we need to encourage more
new blood to go into Parliament new
paper yeah I was I've been considering
standing at the European elections as an
MEP purely because not because my great
ambition in life is to be in Brussels
but I do think that you need new people
straight up
what would inform your decision as to
whether or not you do run in next
month's elections well I think there's a
lot to consider and if you do get
elected it's a huge responsibility and
if you're going to do that job you need
to be in a position where you can do it
properly and make the required
commitment and I need to run that will
be telling Nick Ferrari that will be
telling I've been approached by a few
different people so I would say but one
in particular is quite keen on me could
we register that as a politician's
answer yes which I respect you don't
tell us who it is no just my words point
to the consequences of a broken system I
think that's really important because
actually Europe the European countries
look at us and they and they think why
is it so hard to reach a compromise and
actually it's because the nature of our
system punishes compromise it punishes
moving across the aisle away from your
team because it's an adversarial system
we have the whip and if you don't follow
the line
basically you're punished you lose the
whip we've got this first-past-the-post
system where winner-takes-all in the
constituency so most constituencies end
up with wasted votes so people vote
tactically and not for who they want and
that disenfranchised ISM from the system
because I feel like they're they're
being refused choice and that reduces
participation these all consequences we
have an unelected second chamber the
consequence of which is it you feel
divorced from it you feel powerless to
influence it because they don't have to
answer to the electorate and all of
those consequences mean that when
eventually governments are formed
coalition's aren't necessary and so no
one party has to reach a deal with the
other party to govern actually it's
better that they don't and so we're not
used to governing with other parties and
that leads to a hardening of attitudes
and almost a tribalistic politics and
all of that that I've just listed is
incredibly unhealthy for our country all
the time I've known you Trevor you've
been a fierce defender of democracy how
worried are you when you see the turnout
the other week I'm massively worried
about it and but I I tribute the problem
to something a bit different I think
that the fundamental feeling that most
people have is that politics has given
up on the important issues of our day
and that we can say you know it's about
the divisions of brexit and all the rest
of it but I think the real problem here
is it feels as though politicians have
given up wrestling with the key issues
and they use brexit as a kind of excuse
of that but the big issues that are
changing our society technology
driverless cars digitization
transforming immigration and aging
earlier on the and China these are
bigger problems which will dwarf
whatever happens with brexit and you
know there's a member of the Phillips
family who is now emerging as a major
political star my secret sister she
actually I think has got this and that's
why she's become so popular let's have a
look at what Jess Phillips says
everything that happens in my
constituents lives has been entirely
taken away and there are real stories
real lives real problems in our country
that should be front-page news
in ordinary times and then they're just
been completely forgotten we are at
breaking point here and I don't feel
like Teresa May understands that and she
stands in front of me at the
despatch-box and tells me I'm letting
the people down she wants to come and
sit here
completely right good and the thing is
that we we have seen what is happening
on the continent people lost faith in
conventional politics and as a
consequence their anti-immigrant parties
we've got the single answer single Club
either in government in opposition in
the following countries France Germany
Italy Netherlands Sweden Denmark Hungary
and that's a club that we're about to
join not because we are taking one way
or another on Brixton but because
politics appears to have given up or is
a club we're about to leave if we leave
the European Union is another way of
looking at it the only thing I would add
the thing that definitely still
heartened me and makes me excited about
the processes yes we do have a depressed
vote because our system is broken but
what we do have as well is energized
activists so we have people that are
getting involved that would never have
gotten involved before and I think a
really good example of this is somebody
like an AOC in America who two years ago
was a barmaid she now she's a member of
Congress and I think we're gonna start
seeing more and more characters like
that in Britain as well because we know
we cannot rely on the old tried and
tested type of person that we thought
should be leading that speaks again that
is true June but be careful because you
could also say that about Tommy Robinson
you could but which is why those of us
that love democracy and believe in
inclusion must make sure that we're in
the debate so that this thing goes the
right way very quickly on that one I do
think that that's the view because
European Parliament sarpy are pointing
to you because you might run but because
they are purported those individuals who
are the radicals or that they it's
easier for them to get through in those
elections exactly they performed always
better in the European elections and
these upcoming interactions
I predict Tommy may well run actually
for them because it's proportionate but
just probably win if he did you think
just coming back to someone as you
rightly say the last couple questions on
this from me and I you know once in the
Sun always in the Sun the person who
might be talking to you about running
does he have the same initials for the
same radios to be a situation where
there is a burn a fighter party that's
just a decent party that is pro brexit
that is not extreme in either way what I
would look to see is a pro in surprise
party that's pro caring for those that
need it that's pro brexit and
implementing breaks it properly that
doesn't exist I would love that package
DSD people I met with ASD decent because
I probably won't do it it's a lot they
do seem to fit the description you just
mentioned I mean they're not associated
with extremism whatsoever they're Pro
brexit they are also when I just say one
thing before you go into your topic
the other place the the initials that
are the same as his don't do it from
politics to sex let's move on and after
the break
I'm calling for men's a stepper when it
comes to contraception
[Music]